hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 14 video it's
part one of a two-part episode all about
Jonathan crane and the Scarecrow pushing
into scarecrow territory this soon is a
really big deal mostly what I've seen
the showrunners talk about with respect
to the back half of season 1 is just
transitioning Edward nygma into his
Riddler persona just pushing him further
down that path the real star of the
episode was Julian Sands guesting as dr.
crane or his father however you want to
think about it so we have to talk about
him first ok so just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet starting with top five
moments number five meet the fearsome
dr. crane I just love some of the titles
Gotham picks for its episodes very on
the nose but totally appropriate so in
keeping with the tradition of this show
it being a prequel we meet the
Scarecrow's father he's the one that got
him into the business so to speak or
inspired him into the business or scared
him into the business I guess depending
on how you look at it and who better to
do it the Julian Sands he's done some
really awesome low-budget horror films
so he feels like a natural fit for this
character someone who is very good at
scaring other people the twist is is
that he's extracting their adrenal
glands so this is probably like a
precursor to the fear toxin he's trying
to create a form of that it's the same
thing with the Viper in the venom serum
eventually the venom serum comes along
much later in the continuity so fear
toxin also coming many many years down
the road with the help of reishi Algol
depending on whether you're looking at
the comic books or the film's I love the
logic that he spouts out it's for
Humanity it's for the common good
all the speechifying he did about his
son in the fear group it actually
sounded a little authentic I actually
think he was telling the truth when he
said he was afraid of being a failure
I think the device of the group itself
was a little corny like that that was a
little weird
I'm sure groups like that exist in real
life but it feels a little contrived he
is a doctor so they could have just made
him a normal psychiatrist and just have
him prey on his patients maybe they just
didn't want to be too on the nose
whenever Bullock was talking about his
fears I thought that he was trying to
lay a trap like he thought someone
inside the group was doing it so he was
trying to bait them that all went out
the window the minute he took miss
Mullen which actually dovetails with a
funny romance subplot really nicely
moving on to number 4 Gordon and Bullock
compared dating notes
I love how Bullock tried to explain his
sex life as being quick and dirty
and so funny you really don't get that
from a lot of the versions we've seen of
this character before the bullet
character I feel like whenever they
approach Donal Logue they were like okay
we're gonna give you some liberties to
make this a little funnier than normal
like if you watch the animated series
he's such a depressing character I mean
interesting but very depressing it Donal
Logue does comedy so well so I'm really
glad that the producers are letting him
do a funnier version of Bullock even
though he still is really tortured I
don't really see the Miss Mullen romance
going anywhere I mean that's not gonna
end well
people that meet each other at crime
scenes unless you want a relationship
like Harley Quinn and the Joker you're
just doomed for failure as much as
trauma brings people together it also
just completely messes them up inside
which is why as depressing as it sounds
I don't think that Leslie Thompkins and
Corden are gonna end the season on
really good terms for now that we can
dream we can just have some fun Leslie
Thompkins I would say is probably a
stronger character than both of them put
together I mean yeah not physically
strong but it just seems like she's
better at getting what she wants
there is no series in which Morena
Baccarin is it gonna give some dude the
business I guess that means that on the
flash the Gideon computer is gonna give
Harrison wells the business that would
be funny that would be a twist within
the context of this romance subplot I
think my favorite part was whenever
Gordon was kissing Leslie Thompkins and
nygma slowly shuffled in the background
and just smiled like yeah I did that I'm
the reason that she's gonna come work
here his thing with Miss Kringle is a
little mysterious obviously they're
transitioning him to the Riddler so
they're gonna want to alienate him from
the other characters so I don't think
things are gonna go well with Miss
Kringle later in the season I am curious
to see if they're gonna push her in the
direction of Harley Quinn like she will
be romantically involved with him but
it'll be a really twisted relationship
that would actually be really awesome
let me know if you agree though I mean
you have like more positive
relationships like Leslie Thompkins and
Gordon don't you want to see more
twisted villainous sexual relationships
like say like Bullock and fish Mooney
and now crinkle and the Riddler I don't
really know what their intentions are
for Miss Kringle but but that's what I'm
hoping for number three the penguin goes
on the world's creepiest camping trip
with Moroni this was so great there were
so many jokes on Twitter about this I'm
gonna go see a guy about a thing you
know what I mean that's how you should
describe the app
so to someone it's the episode with the
guy that does that thing you know what
I'm talking about he's the guy that
wears the thing world's greatest recap
of an episode I totally loved David
Zaius it took me a little while to kind
of get into the weird vibe that he was
giving off whenever they were eating
oatmeal and having coffee don't you like
the oatmeal don't you like coffee it
seemed kind of stupid at first but when
you think about it when Yuri watch it it
gets really funny I think that's part of
the charm of Gotham is that yes it seems
really cheesy if you don't think about
it too hard but when you really start
analyzing it and look at what's going on
between those two characters it gets
really funny so you just have to
remember you know as silly as situations
seem it's all intentional it's all done
that way on purpose I was kind of glad
to see David Zaius get some action I
mean he hasn't he hasn't done a whole
lot in the episodes that he's been in
but he did get to give the penguin the
business so he kind of redeemed myself a
little bit and it kind of teed up this
arc imply that we haven't dealt with in
a while moving on to number two he who
controls Arkham controls Gotham just to
be clear he's not referring to Arkham
Asylum specifically its Arkham City so
it's like all the area around Arkham
Asylum they haven't fully explained it
yet the Arkham plot ties in to the Wayne
murders in in like the larger arc of
season 1 there's gonna go all the way to
the finale so this is actually really
important the mob is just part of that
like Falcone Maroni fish Mooney the
other big part of that equation is the
person on the Wayne board behind the
venom serum who is also the person
behind the Wayne murders whether or not
he did it himself I'm curious to see how
Barbara's parents get tied up in that
because there would have been no other
reason to bring them on the show if they
didn't have something to do with one of
the bigger plots and they haven't even
bothered to visit Barbara's character
I'm kind of hoping that she slowly
transitions off the show they can be as
fuzzy as they want about the timeline so
like these five seasons or whatever
however long Gotham runs could just be
the time that he was not married to
Barbara these two episodes right now are
mostly scarecrow episodes so I don't
expect them to get too crazy with Arkham
stuff but we might visit it in the next
episode because it has been a while
since we've dealt with that plotline and
it is really important and my number one
moment
meet Jonathan crane the future Scarecrow
somebody tell that kid to go feed the
meter probably one of the funniest lines
in the episode I'm so happy and
surprised that they brought him on so
soon you
whenever they do things like this like
when they did black mask he has a son
his son will probably be the black mask
from the comics but we don't see him in
this case we actually see the Jonathan
crane that will become scarecrow so it's
a big deal you guys can let me know how
you feel about that about them bringing
these people on so soon especially with
the alter timeline Bruce Wayne being so
young and then being older what it's
doing is is it's erasing some of the
continuity that has to do with the idea
of escalation so Batman comes puts a
mask on so criminals start becoming
super criminals and all the freaks Chron
of the woodwork and that's where you get
people like the Joker and these other
crazy people so the producers have
revealed that they are bringing the
Joker character honor or whoever is
gonna become the Joker before the finale
there will be Joker happenings in season
1 which it which is crazy it just crazy
sounding to me I really did like the way
Christopher Nolan dealt with it the idea
of escalation you start with average
police you get average criminals
represented by the mob you get a
superhero like the Batman
you start getting super villains it's
very logical the way it plays out this
way is just completely different it's
like all the criminals will be there
before Batman ever gets there it's a
chicken in the egg thing Batman lays an
egg it hatches a bunch of super villains
now it's the other way around super
villains chicken lay an egg it hatches
into Batman I don't think it's a
terrible idea but it's a little bit
weird it just takes a little adjustment
so if you're confused about how the
Gotham is changing the timeline that's
what's going on supervillains come first
destroy the city Batman puts on the cowl
as a response here's my big question for
you guys do you actually want to see a
Joker this season in full Joker makeup
or do you feel like it's too soon do you
want them to hold off a little bit
because that's like bringing Superman
onto arrow in season 1 it feels like if
they go to that place too soon then
they're just there won't be that many
places to go in seasons 2 3 4 I think
the flash is a good template it's
bringing big characters on like it's
doing Gorilla Grodd but it's gonna do so
in a way that lets you know that this
isn't a regular thing like he's not
gonna be on the show all the time it's a
very special limited event so we don't
quite know who that person on the boat
with fish Mooney is yet presumably we'll
find out in the next episode I thought I
was so
ridiculous the way they charged each
other is so funny just watching Jada
pinkett-smith just charged at him I
imagine it her and Will Smith have had
some arguments like that at home that
just be so funny just see her charging
Will Smith like a bowl in terms of
Easter eggs I mean I already mentioned
most of I mean scarecrow being the
biggest easter egg
the pig mask does look a little bit like
Professor Pig I think I actually
explained him in my Gotham episode 2
video Grant Morrison created that
character in the comics in reality in
the episode that was not Professor Pig
that character wasn't Professor Pig The
Riddler putting all those body parts in
the locker framing the Emmy that's not a
huge easter egg it's just him getting
nuttier and nuttier eventually what
you'll see is like he'll just get to the
point where he can't distinguish between
right and wrong anymore
he's already kind of there I mean if
he's willing to put a bunch of body
parts in someone's Locker and I just
cannot wait to see him cross that line
I'm just gonna go ahead and take a wild
stab and say it'll have something to do
with Miss Kringle so like I said the
only significant thumbs down I had about
the episode was just the phobia support
group I felt like that was a bit a bit
weird I feel like they didn't need to do
that they could have just had him be a
psychiatrist and abuse his patients let
me know if there's anything else that
you really loved about the episode or
Easter eggs that you spotted but big
stuff happening on arrow in the flash
this week particularly on arrow so
is gonna go down based on a clip they
just released it turns out danny
brickwell killed Malcolm merlyn's wife
if you haven't been watching arrow
Merlyn explained in season one his wife
was murdered at a free clinic she was
working at in the clades danny brickwell
criminal from the glades so turns out
that they're bringing them together in
that way they're binding them across
space and time so everyone is really
hoping Malcolm Merlyn is gonna throw
down I'll be posting those videos after
the episodes there so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I miss my arrow flash Q&A last week but
I'll try to do one this week just
because we're past all the crazy
Superbowl stuff there was some crazy
weird stuff happening on YouTube today
with it not processing videos so if you
miss my constantine episode 11 video you
can click here to watch that tonight
Swamp Thing Easter egg if you guys
spotted it and you can click here to get
ready for arrow in the flash thank you
so much watching so let's all high-five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you